>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So, let me
welcome you all to the African
and Middle Eastern
Division on this beginning
of spring season and New Year.
Happy Nowruz to all of you.
And I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, the Chief of
the African and Middle East Division
and I'm delighted to be
able to greet you this way
since we have Professor Fatemeh
Keshavarz with us to open the season
with her new book, Lyrics
of Life: Sa'di on Love,
Cosmopolitanism and Care of Self.
What could a more auspicious title
with which to start the New Year.
As most of you already
know our division is made
up of three sections, the
African, the near east
and the Hebraic sections were
responsible for materials
for 78 different countries in
the near east, Central Asia,
the Caucasus, as well as
from the entire continent
of Africa, North and Sub-Sahara.
And we're very active in
acquiring, developing collections,
briefing visitors coming from
all the countries of the region.
Organizing programs,
symposia, workshops, exhibits.
We also invite scholars and experts,
we have researched and down work
on our areas of responsibility.
And we invite them to share
with us their ideas, their work,
their research, so that
we learn from them.
And so, that our collections
come a live.
And who could best put
the Persian collections
and make them alive than Fatemeh.
And although Hirad is
going to introduce her,
I want to say just briefly, a few
things, a few personal things.
I got to know Fatemeh Keshavarz
on the Persian book
exhibit a few years ago
and discovered what an
extraordinary woman she is.
She is a really SAS woman, a poetess
of incredible talent, a writer,
a thinker, an artist, scholar,
a woman of so many dimensions
that it is difficult
to find the words.
And I'm going to let her speak in
her own way to say those things.
And so that you can have
a sense of who Fatemeh is.
But, so you would end for the treat.
I'm telling you this.
And, now Hirad is going to
officially introduce her, so Hirad.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank
you, thank you very much.
Thank you, Mary-Jane for
a wonderful introduction.
I'm delighted that you could make
it here in the middle of a workday.
It's-- I know not easy to get to
the Library, not that convenient.
This is the season for Nowruz and
New Year, the arrival of spring.
I want to wish everyone who
celebrates Nowruz a happy spring
as well as to other folks who enjoy
seeing nature come back to life.
This is a tradition celebrated
all the way from the western gates
of China if you like
Central Asia, Afghanistan,
Iran, into Anatolia the Kurds.
And it is a age-old tradition
that this entire region celebrate.
I would like to also say that it is
quite wonderful to see that Iranian
and Afghan and Central Asian
communities here making this a
tradition that has become part
of the American culture
in recent years.
And every year you have more
and more extensive
gatherings and ceremonies.
You would also like to then switch
to our wonderful collaboration
with Dr. Keshavarz and the
University of Maryland.
I could not have put together
the exhibit without the expertise
and the help of Dr. Keshavarz and
the wonderful staff that she has,
at UMD at University of Maryland.
I would take a second
and read her bio.
She really doesn't
need an introduction.
Everyone knows who she is, but it
would be right here to at least
and would be a right thing
to do to introduce her.
Let me quickly put up
the program as well.
Today's program is
focusing on the new book
that Dr. Keshavarz has put out.
And she will be speaking to you.
Her accomplishments are extensive,
so I'm going to quickly go over it
and I'm sorry if I don't cover
everything, my apologies.
Fatemeh Keshavarz is a director
of the school of languages,
literatures, and cultures,
and the chair and director
of Roshan Institute for Persian
Studies at the University
of Maryland College Park.
And Dr. Keshavarz was born and
raised in the City of Shiraz,
completed her studies in Shiraz
University and University of London.
She taught at Washington University
in St. Louis for over 20 years
where she chaired the Department of
Asian and Near Eastern Languages,
literatures from 2004 to 2011.
In 2012, Dr. Keshavarz has
joined the University of Maryland
as a Roshan Institute chair in
Persian Studies and director
of Roshan Institute
for Persian Studies.
Dr. Keshavarz is author of
award winning books including
"Reading Mystical Lyric: The
Case of Jalal al-Din Rumi,
Recite in the Name of the Red Rose,"
and a book of literary analysis
of social commentary
titled, "Jasmine and Stars:
Reading more than Lolita in Tehran."
She has also published other books
and numerous journals and articles.
She has a published poet in
both Persian and English,
an activist for just
justice and peace.
And she was invited to speak
at the UN general assembly
on the significance
of cultural education.
Her NPR show, "The Ecstatic Faith
of Rumi" brought her the
Peabody award in 2008.
And the same year she received
the Hershel Walker Peace
and Justice award.
I think I said long enough list.
There is more, but I would like
to invite her so she can speak.
Thank you very much.
OK. Thanks very much.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Thank you so much.
I'm really speechless.
Thank you.
I hope that what I present
meets the expectation after all
of this love and, you know,
amazing words given to me.
Let me just briefly say that the
collaboration with the Library
of Congress is being equally great
joy for me and for University
of Maryland just being in this
amazing space dedicated to learning
and to supporting those who work
to learn is in itself epic really
and we're wonderful to be--
feel wonderful and wonderfully
fortunate really to be a part of it.
So thank you so much.
So, today I'm going
to talk about Sa'di
and although I'm speechless
he never was.
So hopefully something
beautiful and wonderful will come
out of everything that
he has said in his life
and there was plenty
that he did say.
And what I'm hoping that by the end
of this hour you have is a taste
of what the title of this talk
is giving which is whose idea
as a lover, as cosmopolitan
traveler, and as an educator
as a person who care
about helping people build
and rebuild their selves.
I'm hoping that you get a
taste of his words and the pure
and strong sensuality which is a
very important part of his work.
The spiritual capacity that
he brought through his words,
the ethical values that he
put forwards the cosmopolitan
consciousness that he supported, the
social awareness that was connected
with his work, the very lively humor
and I'm going to put a little bit
of emphasis on that and of
course, his poetic precision
about which I'm going to say
a few words at the very end.
So, let me say why I'm saying,
a taste, because I really think
that there is not enough
room to do any kind
of in-depths dipping to his work.
But, what I'm hoping is that you'll
do that afterwards, that everybody,
they would be looking for
translation of Sa'di's work,
that you would be looking for
everything that people wrote on
and because of the
taste that I have given.
Let me also by way of a
methodological note say
that I believe that every work of
criticism of analysis has to go
in two different directions.
It has to analyze and criticize the
subject matter that it is focusing
on and it-- at the same time
has to stay critical of itself.
In other words, it has to-- what you
are doing, and why you're doing it,
and the way you are doing
it as the analytical person,
as the person providing the analysis
has to be at the same time more
or less even on the same level
that your analysis of
the other work goes.
So, why am I doing-- why am
I writing Sa'di for example?
He is virtually unknown
to English speakers.
He was a trendsetter.
Now, a lot of people will say, there
are many ways to study literature,
you don't have to just go
to big names, great man,
particularly most of
them were big man.
But I would say that many traditions
have their great people not
yet known, not yet brought
out in to the consciousness
of the literary consciousness
of the world.
At large and Sa'di is one of them.
And that he represents in
many ways a very diverse
and very complex literary tradition.
So it's not just him,
it's what he carries
with him through the centuries.
He's also very keen on
experimenting with a wide range
of generic possibilities.
So, it almost leaves no
generic form and touched except
for I think [inaudible]
they showed quite traits.
I don't know that he
ever really showed
that much interest in that form.
And he penetrates this
temporal distance
that we have which is 800 years.
It's not a joke.
And he really speaks with you
as if he's a poet sitting next
to you writing his words today.
And despite all of these, he
went through the 20th century
as not only-- not really
very well-known
but heavenly criticized
particularly by Iranian critics.
But many others as well, and as we
look at the work that he produced
that should come to the surface
why that happened in part was
because he had such
mastery of the language.
It almost seemed magical.
And so people began to think of
him as something of a wordsmith,
something of a magician with words
and really didn't do much
focus on the content.
Others criticized him for
praising kings and we are going
to talk about that a little bit.
So, for all these reasons I thought
that here is somebody to talk about.
Besides the fact that it
was really a great joy
to read him again and
to write about him.
Now, in terms of dates,
his dates are 1210 to 1291.
We are not absolutely certain
about the date of his passing.
That's true of many
people of that era, also,
because it became a
legendary figure.
I mean, it was really
impossible to be a Persian speaker
and not know something of Sa'di.
There are so many anecdotes
where you go somewhere
and somebody discovers in
Tajikistan, in Uzbekistan,
in India that you are
a Persian speaker
and the first thing they
say, [foreign language],
what do you know of Sa'di's works?
So, when you get to that
level, people give you the kind
of velvet cloak of invented stories.
So, there's also a lot of
inventive stories about him.
Fourteen trips to Mecca, you know,
who knows if he really traveled
to Mecca 14 times or not.
But, we're going to try to see
who he is through his work.
And I think that is a good decent
way of doing it, although, you know,
not everything that everybody
creates is absolutely,
factually true about who they are,
but it's a version of
telling themselves.
So, it's a important version
of telling themselves.
So, the other methodological point
I'm brining to your attention is
that I'm going to foreground
his poetry.
And I'm going to go with that.
Now, there's analysis,
there's theoretical discussion,
but I'm not good in
foreground those.
I don't think those
are there in order
to be the main topic of discussion.
They're kind of there to
help you move forward,
to find your way around.
And I try to keep them where
I believe they need to be.
Now, the first thing, Sa'di
is a lover par excellence.
He is lover.
Nobody can ever argue
with that, that sensual,
this wordly as well as spiritually.
And it's fantastic that
he doesn't really try
to separate the two
that drastically.
And, you know, that is actually
true of some other medieval poets
of the Islamic tradition as well.
And that's a different story all by
itself that the division of the body
and the soul as they exalted
as-- and base happens later on.
And it's much more a kind of
European influence on that debate,
but let's go back to that.
He is a lover par excellence.
[ Foreign Language ]
"Tonight that my sweetheart is
holding me tight, if they'd burn me
like al of wood, I'll feel
nothing but the light.
When you have what you
want, death has no meaning,
arrows of hardship fell
in me, I will not fight.
Tonight, my moon and I are
ecstatic being together.
Tell the heavens to close
its gates on sunlight.
Has the star of dawn risen?
Is this really you?
Or are my eyes deceiving me?
Perhaps this is the night
of power, that luckiest
and most blessed of nights.
Oh, how I want us to sleep in the
orchard and taken the garden scent
if the birds of dawn
wouldn't agitate
and wake us before
the morning light.
With these eyes, with
these eyes that are looking
at you this wonderful
moment, tell me,
how do I ever contemplate
any other sight?"
"Talk to me there are no
strangers here just the two of us.
All right, there is that candle.
I'll cut his tongue and
take away its light.
Now, there is nothing between
us except this garment.
If it keeps us apart I'll tear
it open with love's joyful might.
And I just want to tell you
that this is ghazal [assumed
spelling] that, you know, you--
almost any educated Iranian
would, no, at least partly
by heart, [foreign language].
And I initially translated
this as a gift
to my wonderful student Matthew
Miller [assumed spelling]
and his wife when they got married
and I read it on their wedding.
But, the very last one,
[foreign language], the garment,
there's only this garment
between you and me.
And if it keeps up apart, I'm going
to tear it open with love's might.
That's written on my
father's tombstone.
He requested that.
He requested that because he
saw the body as the garment
and he saw the passing as
an embracing of the beloved.
I just want to give you
a taste of how diverse,
how versatile this understanding of
the line can be and how this idea
of being a lover moves in
many different directions,
not just one linear way, in
many different directions.
And Sa'di is indeed one of the
best literary embodiment of it,
keeping the body and the
soul together, the wedding
and the passing together.
Life in all it's complexity.
Now, the next thing I would
like to say about Sa'di is
that he was a season traveler.
For 30 years in his life, like or
when he was very young he left Iran,
he went to Baghdad,
he studied there,
and he actually became a
professor in the Nezumia [phonetic]
of Baghdad, but then he left.
He left and he traveled
for almost 30 years.
We are told and in many ways it's
quite possible that he went westward
as far as Africa and
eastwards as far as China.
There are fictions
about the travels.
So he wrote about them too.
And, you know, he said himself
that, [foreign language],
those who travel much
tell tall tales.
So, right, OK, don't
take everybody I say.
Everything I say as factual which
I think is absolutely wonderful
because it says that he understood
factuality in a different way.
He understood his perception
of what he saw on the way
and around the world as his
way of bringing the world
to his leadership whether
it wasn't always absolutely,
factually accurate or not
did not matter as much.
Now, that also gave him sense
of the world which I think much
of the world did not come to
develop until far later than that.
I'll give you a story.
[ Foreign Language ]
Something like that.
OK.
[ Foreign Language ]
That's what I want.
So, somebody came from the sea of
Oman and he had traveled a lot.
He had seen Arabs,
Turks, Tajiks and Greeks.
And what's the next line?
[ Foreign Language ]
So, in his pure soul, he had
collected a lot of knowledge.
In other words, see these people
were not barbarians they weren't
just strangers out there.
We didn't know anything
about, they new things
and you could learn from them.
I have the Persian written here,
right, fondly I had looked.
OK. So when he comes back after the
30 years of traveling he comes back
to Fars, to the province of
Fars in [inaudible] Shiraz
and where Abukbakzad Gersneji
[assumed spelling] is the ruler.
And so, he begins to compose some
of his great works like Gulistan
and Bustan to actually dedicate
to the ruler and to the brother,
public, which is he is very aware of
in terms of wanting to see his work.
Now, when he does this, with it,
there is also praising of the kings
which was very, very common at that
time and its part is that process
of math and he talked about
how powerful they were.
He also talked about
who they should be.
Something that a lot of other people
of his time didn't have either the
weight or the courage to do, now,
the critics didn't take
lightly to this somebody
like Jan Repka [assumed spelling]
for example, since what can I say
about somebody who
praises Halahkuh [phonetic]
and also praises the person who
kills halahkuh and, you know, but,
I think that what we missed in this
is actually look at these words
of praise and see what they are.
What are they about?
And I'm going to give you a taste of
a little bit of that because, again,
now we're talking about Sa'di,
the praise writer for the kings.
So, in 1290-- I'm not
actually sure if it's 1291,
because that would be
very close to his passing.
But it's a date given usually.
He wrote this famous Qasidas
[assumed spelling] that, again,
a lot of Iranians know by heart.
[ Foreign Language ]
So, he wrote this beautiful
poem dedicated
to Olko [assumed spelling].
And you can tell from the beginning
of this, "much has the world turned
and turn it will, the wise
do not get attached to death
which does not keep still.
Do whatever you can
when you are able
to before old age takes
the strength from you."
So, this is the beginning
is a clearly addressed
to a much broader audience then and
to a newer, any other, you know,
other ruler or great person.
And then he does something
which is also very traditional,
which is going back to
the authoritative voice.
That is the old fables
and books of kings.
Sorry, that in the old
fables and books of kings.
There are tales of Rostam, immortal
Esfandiyar and such things is
for the rulers and the owners
of wealth to understand
that the world was before
them in other people's hands.
So, like he's going
to get to the praise
at some point but this
is before that.
There are-- those are all gone, but
blinded with greed, we do not seem
to learn a lesson to take hit.
So, still talking to people,
OK, and Jan was there too.
And by now, he has established the
power of his voice and the power
of his work and it's really
through the majesty of the words
that he has the authority to do it.
The king knows how much
people value this, OK?
Sa'di also know there is something
called, too much advice to those
in possession of power, so
he's kind of watches his steps.
I am talking to you, who
were an oblivious cell,
then group into a suckling
babe and who could tell
that in no time you would be
grown and already to greet life
as a Cyprus faded beauty.
More time passed, you made
yourself a name as brave
on the battle field as
in any hunting game.
What ever you saw did
not stay still.
Do not think that it
now or ever will.
So, you know, you want to read it as
talking to people, but battlefield,
you know, all these beginning
to really address the king.
Sooner or later, this form of yours
so beauty as unfair will be dust
and even then scattered in the air.
Surely, the gardener will
pick the flowers all and those
which he does not pick
perish and fall.
This all amounts to nothing.
Things which you cannot
own happiness, victory,
being in command, sitting
on the thrown,
indeed leaving a good
name behind is much better
than an old made palace
adorn with gold and silver.
So, there is now no doubt
who is being addressed,
and Sa'di becomes more specific.
What will next year bring,
nobody would know or the friend
that we had last year
where did he go?
And so, you know, that
is also very much inline
with the historical
events in Shiraz.
I mean, people are
being coming and going
and you all know he's
very aware of that.
So, before the passage
of time and the turning
of the wheel takes the range from
your hands and you lose the deal.
So, your seeds for the
harvest, do not idly sit.
If you want a treasure,
get working for it.
Since God has given you
greatness and power,
do not look down at the
poor from your ivory tower.
Since the heavens have given you
the upper hand to those who are
under you be gentle and kind.
Those who come to apologize
and to confess protect their
lives, show them forgiveness.
And then, he becomes even more
specific because the kings used
to defame people who
came before them.
So, he says, you know, do not defame
the good names of other people.
Think of those who come
after you and so on.
And, finally, finally, Sa'di,
say whatever you know
without hesitation.
The truth must not be
told except in the open.
The one who is not held back by
fear or greed speaks in the face
of the enemy without heat.
I pray for the Nazent
fortune of our great king.
Now, we've got to the praise.
To be on the rise and long
lasting, our just monarch,
our elastious Amir
[assumed spelling],
the noble anchiano [phonetic],
the ruler without fear,
others bring our sovereign
gifts of sweet meat,
I pour the jewels of
my words at his feet.
People usually praise
and panegyrize the ruler,
I offer him my simple
words of prayer.
Oh, Lord, please steer
him towards kindness
and make his life long
and prosperous.
May forever your wishes be fulfilled
and your enemy vanquished
in the battlefield.
I think that really rest the
case for praise, because--
no, there is a lot more to that
poem, I really shortened it
because we don't have time.
For all of that at some point
God comes into the picture,
but it becomes like a triangle
people, God, ruler, it's not--
it's that kind of a very complex
interaction between the two.
And I want it from there, I want to
take us to Sa'di a teacher of ethics
who is really an extension of what
you saw, but it's far more fun
to read because what he
decides is that I'm not going
to just give another boring book of,
you know, directions and guidelines.
I'm going to tease people out
of the situations they are.
And so that they begin to think
and, you know, he's very foucauldian
in the sense that power
flows in the society.
There are what, freedom
also flows in this society.
You have to find your ways
to navigate your freedom.
You learn your rules of decency.
Sometimes you just evade
something if you need to,
it's very practical
and very open about.
But in all of it, his teach--
his teaching his ethics.
There's a long story that I'm
not going to really get in to
and that is there is this king,
he's drunk and he's singing
and then he sing saying
that, you know,
there is no better
moment in the world.
I'm having this great time and, of
course, there's this homeless man
who is sitting outside and hearing
the king and he says, "Oh, you know,
if the king doesn't have
any worries on his mind?
May he have some for the likes
of me, you know, we are in need."
And the way that you
hear the homeless man
and really accept him is
because Sa'di gives him
the exact same eloquence
that he gives the king.
So, you have to hear him.
He has this powerful poetic, logic
of that about which I'm going
to say a little bit at the very end.
So the king says, he gets very
embarrassed then he says, "You know,
hold the-- your cloaks so
I can throw a pouch of gold
or whatever down for you."
And he says, "Oh, I would
if I was wearing one."
And so, he doesn't have
really good clothes on either.
So the king goes down
and gives him something.
And then this guy turns
into, of course,
he doesn't know how
to spend his money.
He has never had money
to know how to manage it.
So he spends and it comes
back and makes the king angry.
And then the vizier comes in and
says, "You made a lot mistakes.
First of all, you gave him too much.
Secondly, you gave him
all at the same time.
Thirdly, you cannot be kind
and then when people come
to you turn then away with anger.
That doesn't describe
greatness," you know.
So, in that one story, you actually
see all the different dimensions
of how to communicate,
how to deal with--
at the larger society
if you own something.
So when people say, "Sa'di wrote
a lot about rich people" yes,
but he talked about how they
should live their lives as well.
And he also had a lot of
room for non-rich people.
And then not everything that he says
is really quite as elaborated that,
sometimes it's very brief.
There is this young boy who
wakes up every morning and prays
and he's very proud of being able,
before sunrise and pray and that's,
of course, very difficult
for a young person and one--
and probably Sa'di
himself, I don't know.
So he turns to his father at some
point in the morning and he says,
"None of those folks rise to offer
a humble morning prayer to the Lord,
so deep, are they in
their heedless slumber
that they might just well be dead?"
And the father does not rest a bit,
he says, "If you have reason to spy
on others judging by
what you just said,
you too my dear son would
be better off in bed."
So, it really is-- these moments,
these very brief moments I cannot
tell you how many Iranians actually
know this.
And so, he's kind of penetrating
the consciousness of a much larger,
much more complex body
of people who hear it.
Similarly, there's a story.
I love this one.
There are two boys talking.
One of them is rich and the other
one is poor and the rich boy says,
"I like you father's tomb."
He brags, my father is decorated
with beautiful calligraphy written
on the halfty piece of marble
in laid with turquoise.
How interesting, observes
the poor boy,
before you dad moves beneath the
way to mine has reached paradise.
So, if you have Sa'di the
ethical teacher or the ethicist,
really using a language which is
very reachable, very beautiful,
very humorous, and that
is what keeps the work,
that the book is still taught in
schools in Iran, in university
and in schools because you can
really go to it at different levels.
But I'm going to focus for the
ending of this pretty much on,
what I described as
Sa'di the comedian.
And I really mean the comedian.
Excuse me, I'm piercing
in, ending of a cold, so.
And I even thought about
calling him a jester,
because he does a lot jesting.
But, I didn't go for the word
jester because jesters are usually
in courts of kings
and that he did not do
that for it isn't in that setting.
So, jester would not
have been the right word.
I went for comedian
because he's very humorous,
jesting, he runs around you.
You never know where he's going
to show up next in the next line.
You know, he's talking to
you, he's suddenly talking
to somebody else very, very
playful, but also he's very alert,
very witty, street wise, he uses
a language that he doesn't use
in the other more formal
kinds of ghazal writing.
And, he's a survivor.
I'm going to tell you
why in a second.
So, this is-- for this he uses
a form called [inaudible] is
like a ghazal, you read a body
of like poetry then you come back
to a refrain that gets repeated, OK.
So this refrain keeps the whole
thing together, very tightly,
but allows you to move around
in the middle of the ghazals.
So it's a combination of freedom
and also being bound by rules.
Now, a lot of you Iranians
are going to recognize this.
[ Foreign Language ]
OK, let me give you a
translation in a second.
So, this comes finally-- actually
let me give you a translation first
because it helps then
putting it together.
A figure so fine it
cannot tolerate close.
Tearing them open like a
pod blooming into a rose.
Standing on the rooftop
where the moon will appear,
who can tell if it
is the moon or her?
An arm full of flowers.
No, no, she's a full garden and not
just any, but the Garden of Eden.
Are those fragrant polo balls
she hides under her dress
or is it the aroma of her
breath sweet as [inaudible].
So, this is the sensuality
I'm talking about.
It just runs through
the whole thing.
But then you come to
the refrain which is--
[ Foreign Language ]
So, every ghazal is ended with
a go about doing my own things.
Waiting patiently for
whatever life brings.
No commitments.
No-- I have nothing to lose.
I'm just this very plain
poor ordinary person.
And inserted into this
is extreme moments
that other forms of
lyric do not allow.
Like--
[ Foreign Language ]
May every Cyprus tree on the edge
of a stream be a sacrifice
to your beauty, so pray.
So you-- it's a-- that
exaggeration is on the surface.
It wants you full grounded.
It wants you to see it.
And then there is that lot of also,
"I'm an outcast, nobody
cares about me.
Everybody is blaming me."
[ Foreign Language ]
So they blame me.
They said, "Don't go after her,
she's going to ruin your life"
and I tell them, "You are having
the heart and weak and emotion.
Is this what you call loyalty?
Is this what you call devotion?
That I go about doing my own things?
Waiting patiently for
what life brings".
So, see how the refrain
this, completely transformed.
A moment ago, it was I'm going to go
about doing my own things
and, you know, I don't care.
Now, he said, are you telling me
to go about doing my own things?
At this every, every
ghazal opens a new window.
Suddenly we find our selves in
the company of animals, you know,
I am like a bird that went after
a sea and fell into a trap.
You know, like a wolf
who coveted the sheep
and of course got caught, you know.
And wonder why is he doing this?
What are we getting at?
What is this doing in the
middle of this love story?
And you, suddenly, by the time
you come to the end, you realized,
he is telling as each
one of us is a zoo.
Watch it. You know, feel your
feelings, and know who you are.
Otherwise, you are going to face
this bunch of animals that you are.
Who in many ways are lovely
and lively and beautiful,
it's not basic but watch it.
This is who you are.
Know yourself.
Or, suddenly, in another stanza,
he starts focusing in Arabic.
Uses this exaggerated Arabic terms
that, I'm sure Arabs wouldn't use.
And Arab speaker really, you know,
and even Persians using Arabic,
if you can see the exaggeration
and you think, yeah, but,
what are you up to, you know?
And then suddenly get
to the point, you know,
I'm eloquent in all the
languages that I speak.
When I begin to describe you,
I sound like a dumb fellow.
And so, you go back then you see,
so what is he doing with language?
She's brought, there is opening up
of the possibilities of what we do
with language and particularly
a criticism of flowery
and exaggerated language, but people
quoted Arabic in order to show
that they are highly educated.
Now, I'm aware that we're
getting fairly close.
So, not going to extend
as far too much.
Let me just give you
another, another example.
Everyone once in a
while he makes a puzzle.
You know, and this is in the area
of still Sa'di the comedian, OK.
So, he is like-- he-- I always have
a feeling that from some corner
of the book he's laughing
at you as you're doing this.
It's like for example
he says, "Cruel you are.
You did this to me, did this
to me" and then it ends.
From now on, do not do what you
have done so far for if you do,
I swear to God, that I will
henceforth-- " and I'm like, oh,
"What is he going to do?"
You know, go about doing my
own things waiting patiently
for whatever life brings.
So, again, he just tells you
that that little refrain,
these moments in life where
we always jump back to,
could be translated into
so many different things
by what comes before and what comes
after, and there is a lot more
to language than what the kind of
dictionary meaning looking up that
where you often-- we get trapped in.
So, let me conclude by saying
that, I think of some --
and one of my chapters is called
the "Old Church" that, "The Garden",
you know, it says and
that is because I came
to see Sa'di's work very
much in that metaphor.
And one of the tastiest fruit of the
exploration of this garden was that,
when I started my initial
research on Sa'di, you know,
and I know it is-- I've lived with
this poetry all my life as a master
of originality, of
freshness and color and humor
and elegance and I could go on.
And I started collecting
main themes,
like what themes are
going to come out of this?
And you know then, I
had the shock of my life
because the basic core
concepts he dealt
with were mostly a dozen
or dozen and a half.
I almost fell off my
kind of proverbial chair,
like, how do you do this?
How do you bring so much freshness
with so little traditional
language at your disposal?
And so, I began to read about
the concept of repetition,
the concept of making things new
and basically explore
the concept of speaking.
So, that might be probably
the biggest gift
that I got out of these book.
And that is, how is that
the poets create freshness
with anything that they touch?
Even with familiar ideas.
Oh how is it that what
they say convinces us?
You know, and that brought
me to a lot of reading
about how language refies things.
How-- What is it-- I have disposal
at language if we don't stretch it
with poetry, could refi things.
Even when we say, for example,
change is great, right,
is turns change into a thing,
as if change was a thing, like,
you know, this room is great.
Where as in fact change is a
combination of a set of shifting
and evolving moments of emergence,
of new ideas, of combinations,
of all kinds of variations on
the themes and we manage to kind
of the-- or either the language
takes the ability from us to see
that and that is how great poets
come, you know, into the picture
by creating the poetic process of
revival, rearrangement, shifting,
combining the previous patterns
and giving birth to the settle
and constant process of remaking.
And I think that is really
the key word for Sa'di.
And just like a million
tress, a leaves--
or a million trees in a
garden will not be repetitive.
A million leaves on a tree
will not be repetitive.
In this poetic combination
and rebuilding things
are not repetitive.
And in fact, they have
their powerful poetic logic.
And I'm going to give you a taste
of it, there's no way to explain it.
I'm going to end with that.
You know, it's like, we can never
say what is funny and a joke.
They can hear it and
laugh at it, OK.
Now listen to this.
This is familiar.
Hamlet says to Horatio, "There
are more things in heaven
and the earth Horatio, than are
dreamt of in your philosophy," OK.
We never doubt him.
Did he really research this?
No, Hamlet says it beautifully.
Shakespeare says it convincingly.
The power of the poetic
logic convinces us.
Now, imagine he would say, "Horatio,
I think there are more things
in heaven and earth that
are dreamt of in your--
", it would have destroyed
it completely.
It would no longer be poetry.
So, that's what I mean with
the power of precision,
of convincing power of poetry
that Sa'di puts such good use.
So, let me end with three lines
of his own vision of the heaven
and the earth which
we cannot argue with.
"The cloak of beauty fits perfectly
on your figure while a
hundred cloaks are torn
by your distraught lover.
Every time, the sun falls
on earth from the heavens,
it is frustrating itself
in your presence.
I will turn into dust and
disappear, but behold,
on my face the dust
of your threshold.
Return the heart that
you stole in daylight
and I'll stop following
you day and night."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you very much,
I would like to give people the
opportunity to ask some questions.
I also wanted to point
out we have copies
of the wonderful book in the back.
At the end, feel free
to go get a book
and Fatemeh again will be
glad to sign it for you.
Any questions?
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Yes, Mary-Jane, please.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well, first
of, thank you, that was--
that was wonderful and
inspiring in many, many ways.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So my question
is, if you were to compare Sa'di
to Rumi or Hafiz, what would stand
out in terms of Sa'di himself?
What would--
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Yeah.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: --
differentiate him, make him unique?
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Yeah,
yeah, actually-- sure.
Yeah. The question is, if
I were to compare Sa'di
to Rumi or Hafiz, for example.
Let me particularly talk about Rumi
and I'm going to come to Hafiz too.
You know a lot of what they
are concerned with is similar
that Rumi is a storm and
Sa'di is a quiet city.
So, a beautifully organized ruled by
law, you know, he breaks the rules
when he likes, but, it is-- you
feel in peace, you're not fighting,
you need to learn, you need to
fall in love and then, you know,
of course, love is going to
have all its ups and downs.
For Rumi, you are-- you
have to break your being
into pieces and rebuild it.
And I think both of them have
a little bit of the other,
when you look for it but
the dominant is there.
For example, when Rumi laughs,
it's the world that's laughing,
that the flowers that
open, everybody who dances,
every thing that grows is a
laughter of a universe and love.
When Sa'di laughs he's
found somebody funny
and he is laughing at them.
So he brings a lot of, I think
a big dose of down to earth.
I was talking to a friend
actually who I think is here,
and now he is sitting there, if
you wanted a metaphor, I would say,
Rumi is here and he is
trying to reach you.
Sa'di is here and he's
trying to connect there.
So it's kind of, in a very
interesting way is this fairly
similar trip, but, you know, I
actually think both of them are
in their own way very
much, very deeply,
rooted in the social
realities of their time.
It's-- I don't-- I do not,
really for a moment agree with--
there's some people who think that,
oh, this exotic poetry is have,
what does it have anything
to do with life?
I think it had everything to
do with struggle and change
and remaking yourself and
reseeing the world and so on.
But, it's a different
kind of perspective.
Now, Hafiz, about whom I really wish
and hope I would have the fortune
of doing some work and
I think is in a way,
a kind of has overlapping
areas with the two, but,
the way he uses language
is completely different.
It's very complex and then
he also plays with spaces.
Space is very important for
Hafiz and I think we have look
at the aesthetics of space
if we deal with Hafiz.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
I'm sure they did.
They-- as you know time wise, they
coincide, there are in fact poems
that sometimes people have
interpreted as alluding
to each other, but,
you know, I'm not--
I'm not so sure that we
have any factual reason.
You know, the way I see it is that
this language is highly, you know,
that what they do is
highly intertextual.
The tradition and the
language carries it.
So, Sa'di is here, but he is
many places at the same time.
Same as true of Rumi, so in a way
they are in constant encounter
with each other through the medium
of this overarching,
very complex tradition.
But in terms of personally having
come in to contact or written
about each other, I
don't-- I don't know of it.
I don't think so.
Yes.
>> I know it's incredibly
difficult to translate into English
and to me it sounds beautiful--
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you.
>> You've done fantastic job.
Could you describe a couple
of challenge you've faced?
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Yes.
>> [Inaudible] it into English.
And also how suddenly have
influenced your own writing.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Absolutely.
Tet me answer the second one
first because I'd really want it,
you know, translation as
a big love of my life,
so I'm going to come back to you
and be a bit more long winded.
I think the language I have
written-- I have a book on Rumi,
"Lyrics of Mystical Love."
I think that's written in a language
much closer to the language of Rumi,
even though they're both in English.
Whereas, the language I used
for Sa'di is less abstract,
less stormy, much more accessible.
And so, I think it's an impact
of dealing with his poetry.
In terms of how he has influenced
my education and my thinking
about poetry and all that, it
would really be impossible--
I mean, I grew up with this.
From the moment I remember, you
know, my mother was upset with us,
she would say, [foreign
language], which is to try
to discipline a rascal is like
trying to risk a walnut on top
of the dome, that's Sa'di.
OK. So that is going to roll
down and, of course, you know,
she would look very stern
and she would say this,
but the walnut was rolling down and
so there was laughter, you know.
So he was in, he was in
our lives from that moment
and I think it was an
extremely lucky situation.
I don't know how to thank
my stars for being with my--
the parents who's life
was poetry and we live
in Shiraz and all of that.
So, he influenced us
in all of these.
I mean, when I was a
teenager, I argued with my dad
because I was more Hafiz and he
was more Sa'di but then yeah.
But in anyway, he was there
in one form or another.
In translation, I really want to say
something that I taught translation
because I got really interested in.
And I thought, OK, let me
read more on translation.
And I really came to believe
that, it's a very original work.
If you want to use a metaphor, it's
not like putting something in front
of you and drawing from it.
It's like planting a
seed and let it go.
It's like melting an ice, a
piece of ice which is in a shape
and refreezing it in
a different shape.
It is a lot of originality
in what you do,
but you have to establish
the connection
and try your best to stay low too.
But I also came to
believe that it really--
although things are lost at
translation, no question about it.
But a translation is a
lost and found place.
You also find amazing
things about language
that you would have not done.
So, if you were not translating.
So, I tried to read
and absorb and write.
And then go back and see.
Do I need to get closer to him?
Is this something that it takes away
from what the original is there?
But the answer is,
I enjoy it so much
that it's almost like
writing poetry.
And so, I'm absolutely
grateful for the fact
that he is a translatable poet.
He is, you know, he is
just-- so is Rumi, actually.
Hafiz is far more difficult to
translate because there are dozens
of interconnections between words
and concepts in each line and,
you know, God help you if
you want to translate it.
>> Hirad Dinavari: I would like
to segway into the question
that Joanne asked essential
mention that,
the translation is
she was interesting,
when you seen the Persian
verses, they're gender neutral,
the beloved that he is describing
could be male, it could be female
and your translations are clearly a
references to a women, I'm curious,
how much gender can you read
into it and how much of it--
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: OK.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Then there
is also another criticism
of Sa'di being misogynistic
and being very anti women.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: It
was until the 13th century.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
I know, I'm curious,
and furious to see
what you're doing.
Yeah.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Yes absolutely.
OK. I'm glad you raised
that question on gender
because I read stuff that were
especially, and you're right, the--
pronounced out gender,
non gender specific.
I read poems that are specifically
addressed to females, like,
you know, when you-- somebody
hides polo balls under their dress,
you know, you know, who they are.
But he does have homoerotic imagery
and actually in the chapter on love,
I do have a section, I have
an extended section on that
because people don't know how to
handle it, they try to erase it
by saying, "Oh no, you know, this
is all just metaphoral call."
Some other people say, "OK.
It's just, you know,
it was a tradition.
They did it without
thinking about it."
Now, there's a lot of
discussion that could go into that
which is homoerotic beauty didn't
necessarily mean what we are either
addressing as homosexuality today
and it requires a lot of in depth.
Writing actually matters written on
that beautifully and give a talk.
But, by no means, I want
to take a wider homoerotic.
What I want to say is that,
what happens in the atmosphere
of love makes all of these markers,
gender, class, language, irrelevant.
And there is the emphasis is
on that, that love purifies
and beautifies and makes
it accessible to all.
So, that is very-- not, not that,
you know, you know what I mean.
So, it doesn't just a-- actually,
Kris Tevar [assumed spelling]
has written beautifully on that.
There's a book called,
"The Tale of Love."
I would highly recommend it
to anybody interested in that.
She's written beautifully.
>> Hirad Dinavari: It's
not so much homoeroticism.
To me, it's the genderlessness
freeze the language
in a very interesting way.
And then you translate it into
English, you're be struck.
How-- What should I put here?
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: OK.
>> Hirad Dinavari: A he or she?
You see what I mean?
It's a very interesting.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Yeah.
You do a number of things.
I think if you don't do-- that's
absolutely true because the "Ou"
which could be he or she could be
a king they're praising, a beloved,
a male beloved, a female beloved,
a friend, you know, a master,
a lot of love poetry or
Rumi was written for Shams.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Right.
>> Fatemeh KEshavarz: And
I personally do not believe
that that relationship
was homoerotic.
That's a different
story we can talk about.
So, there's a whole range
of, you know, but is this,
the case of Sa'di, there is.
I mean there is-- There are
beautiful young male he describes
and he says, "I don't want to go
too near because they're dangerous,
you know, I want to get back
home and forget about this."
So he is-- he-- actually,
he's talking about
that very, very openly.
Now, what you do in translation is
that, if you think of translation
in the sense of equivalency
and dictionary,
this equals this, we are in trouble.
But if you think of translation
as you create a context,
you give the meaning then it's--
you don't even have to
exactly repeat the wording.
You make your listener understand
that this is what you think
the context that is going
on which is exactly why you
have to think of translation
as far more complex than just,
you know, finding the meanings
and then transfer it
from one text to another.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Go ahead.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Yes.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Two more question.
You and--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
I am afraid not.
At this point, I think
they might actually do it.
They wrote to me is that, it's
Edinburgh University Press,
but I don't think at
this point it is.
But I prevailed upon them to bring
the price down because, you know,
they-- their price is as--
>> Originally it was 120,
you're getting it for $36, so.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
So I told them,
I'm not going to have any book
signing because it's ridiculous
to stand in front of your friends
and students and colleagues
and say pay $120 from my books.
OK.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Go ahead.
Go ahead, please.
>> I wanted to first of
all thank you very much
because there is nothing
more beautiful [inaudible].
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Thank you.
The significance of?
[ Inaudible Remarks ]
In Baghdad, OK.
OK. Right.
Well. First of all, he lost his
father very, very young and he grew
up in-- I think he left
Shiraz around that time
when he must have been
just under 20.
And again, we don't have a lot of
biographical information about that,
what people tell us is that,
he really wanted a more intense
learning environment and he knew
about Nezamiyeh of Baghdad.
And so, he went there to study.
When he went there to study,
actually, he stayed longer.
So he found the environment
very lively and many
of his little anecdotes, he
refers to the days in Baghdad.
And in one of them, he says
that I had a regular
income through teaching.
And that's how we know
he taught at that point.
He does go back to Baghdad
because he does travel a lot.
But unless we do really a word
search and do an in depth study
of what he else he may have said, I
think Baghdad is a city of learning.
And he actually meet some
of his great teachers there
and stays in touch with them.
So that is-- that I
can say for sure.
I think there was one in-- yeah.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah.
OK. So, let me first say that
probably because he travels so much.
And in some places, he was in a--
economically, he was in difficulty,
didn't-- he run out of
things, he worked and so forth,
and even if not, all of them
would be factually accurate
and part of them would be.
So, he-- when he came back, now the
Shiraz he lived in was the Shiraz
that as the-- the ruler of the time
wanted to rebuild and I'm sorry,
the Ilhanis [assumed
spelling] wanted
to build it back to
as the older time.
They wanted to make a grandeur
that that was there before.
So, when he came back,
he came back to a city
that was fairly prosperous,
although it did have,
of course, obviously a lot of poor.
So in terms of what has
traveled, I think a lot.
I think poets, even to
this day, and I am not able
to really speak accurately to other
Persian speakers like Afghanistan,
you know, Afghan and Tajik
and so on, unfortunately.
But in Iran, to this day, poets
are embodiment of dedication,
telling the truth, speaking
truth to power where, you know,
that really unexpected to be super
humans, it's not good enough.
That was one thing I
discovered when I came
out of Iran poet sold many people,
make all kinds of, you know,
do things that are
not absolutely right.
Now, which doesn't mean
that Iranian poets don't,
but they're not expected
to, you know.
If your [foreign language]
actually said that.
He said, "They write the most
beautiful line and the next day,
go back to be in jealous and petty.
And, you know, how could
you claim to be a poet?"
So, it is a very tightly interwoven
expectation that if you are a poet,
you would be-- you have a
responsibility for speaking.
Not everybody fulfills
that as responsibility
but you're expected to.
And so, I think it has
pretty much lasted.
>> Hirad Dinavari: OK.
Thank you everyone.
You can ask question in person.
Let's go to the books.
I wanted to make sure
that we get a chance
to do the book signing as well.
Dr. Keshavarz is always fantastic
talk, very, very culminating.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you very much.
Thanks for everyone for
coming and making time
out of your busy schedule.
Thank you again.
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.